We'll now discuss more advanced
Datastore topics on
Query, Index, and
Transactions.
These are three topics I'll
cover on this lesson.
How does Datastore
work on Query?
We'll discuss what the reason
is behind these kinds of
restrictions, and how they're
actually an essential
technology to make
it very scalable.
The second topic will be the
workarounds based to overcome
those restrictions.
Then lastly, I'd like
to discuss about
transactions in Datastore.
Because Datastore is not a
traditional database, the
behavior of the transaction
in the Datastore
is completely different.
There's an important concept
called entity groups, which
we'll spend some time on.
So how does Datastore
work on Query?
Bigtable doesn't
support Query.
In ordinary, traditional
relational databases, you'll
always be able to search on the
value of a current column.
But Bigtable doesn't allow
you to do that.
Bigtable can search
only on a key.
Then, how does Datastore
support a Query?
In Datastore, Queries will
be executed as an
index scan of Bigtable.
So this is the big difference
between Datastore in
traditional relational
databases.
Query is executed as
an index scan.
So think about a simple
query like this.
When it's trying to select all
the person entities with
conditions like height property
must be less than 72.
For this query, it will be
executed as a range scan on
Bigtable with an index
table for height.
Recall in the Datastore
introduction session there was
a function called mem scan.
Bigtable can scan on the
key, not on the values.
So by having an index table on
Bigtable like this, which has
the property name and the
property values in its key,
then you can implement a query
like this on Bigtable without
reading the actual values.
Actually, we're using values
from the columns in the key of
the index itself, so that we
can search on the values by
doing the index scan.
This is how data store makes
queries so scalable.
Without any index table, most
of the queries on Datastore
are built through exception,
or you have an error.
But this is quite different than
the traditional indexing
in a traditional database.
In relational databases, you
might want to add an index
just for the performance
issue.
If you don't have any
performance issues, like if
you are just having 100 rows
in a table, then you don't
have to put any index on the
traditional database table.
You can still run a query
without having any index.
But in Datastore, you cannot
execute almost any query on
Datastore without
an index table.
This is not a restriction,
this is a key technology.
It's why Datastore query can
be practically limitless.
If you are using a traditional
database, there's a certain
scalability limit
on the query.
But on Datastore, you can just
run a shard among the multiple
physical servers.
But you don't have to care about
that by yourself, all
the underlying layers, like
Datastore and Bigtable layers,
are taking care of all that,
sharding all the data into
multiple physical servers.
Or, dispatching the
queries onto your
multiple physical servers.
That's not achievable in
a relational database.
The most important point is
that the index scan makes
query performance for the size
of your results, not
with the data set.
So no matter how many entries
you have, it doesn't affect
your performance
of your query.
Your query performance will be
affected only by the size of
the result set.
If you are trying to get
millions of records as a
result set, you will decrease
your query performance.
The size of the whole data set
won't affect your query
performance.
But how does this support
various queries
just by index scans?
As you saw, the index scan
mechanism is so simple.
So you might wonder how it
can support complex query
conditions like WHERE
or ORDER BY clauses.
The answer is various kinds of
index we have on Datastore.
One is the single-property
index.
Single-property index will be
working for queries with a
simple sorting or filtering,
just like this.
So here's a sample query with
very simple conditions, like
name property equals John.
If you ran a query like this,
this query will be converted
into an index scan on
the single-property
index for name property.
For every single-property or
entity there will be a
single-property index
automatically created for you.
You don't have to define
explicitly
to build that index.
Every single property index will
be automatically created
for all properties.
So if you're entity has a
property called name, then the
single-property index will
be created automatically.
And if you execute a query
like this, then it'll be
converted and executed
as a range scan
on this index table.
Or index scan for a key for
a parent name and John.
This is actually a key
of the index table.
So these are the keys of the
index table and they should be
a value, which is the key
for another table.
This is how you can write
the simple query on
Datastore in Python.
Because you are not directly
handling your Bigtable, you
can just use the simple query
language like this.
This is another example of the
queries that is executed to be
a single-property index, which
has the unique quality of
filtering, like the
greater than,
equals, or if-then operators.
And also, sorting using
the ORDER BY
clause on a single property.
We're still handling filtering
or sorting on just one
property, so that those queries
can be handled by the
single-property index.
If you are handling just one
property on your query, then
these queries can be executed
as a range scan on a single
property index scan.
In this case, it's trying to
find a name which starts with
B, so it will be converted to a
range scan from Bob to Brad,
for example.
And there's something else you
should notice, that that
single property index actually
uses two index tables.
One is an ascending table and
another is a descending table.
So every single property there
will be two index tables
automatically created.
So the single-property index can
support queries like this,
like the equality filters.
At this point, for this
particular query, you don't
have to have a composite index
that'll be discussed later.
Because Datastore will merge the
results of the queries for
each properties into
one automatically.
So Datastore will execute a
query for the first name
equals Bob, and then execute
a query for our
last name equals Jameson.
Then, merge the result
into one.
Also, inequality filters, or not
equals attribute, can be
executed by the
single-property index like this.
And not equal to filter, like
last name not equal to Bob
will be converted internally
as a query like this.
This should be or actually.
First name Bob, this will
also be handled as a
single-property index, too.
Let's discuss the more
complex query.
For more complex queries that
would involve more than one
property, you would need to
create an index code or
composite index.
This is also known as
a custom index.
This is an example of the query
for composite index.
If you are using an inequality
filter on one property and
combining it with the inequality
filter on another
property, then you would
need to build your
composite index for that.
And a composite index
has a logical value.
It has values for logical
properties, like kind name and
values for the last name and
values for the first name, so
that this Datastore can convert
this kind of complex
query into a simple
index scan.
The combination can be very
complex, with lots of tables
being created for that
composite index.
You, the developer, have to
explicitly define that by your
configuration file.
This is an example of a query
for a composite index.
In Java, you can specify that
in a file called Datastore
index, or in the index.yaml
file.
In Python, you can just use
your index.yaml file.
Or you can write the definitions
of the composite
index like this.
You can specify the kind name
and the rest the properties
with the property name and the
directions you want to have.
By specifying this in deploying
this application
onto the cloud, Datastore will
start building the composite
index for you.
Composite indexes can support
queries like this as we just
saw in this example.
The queries with the inequality
filters, inequality
filters on other properties,
or the queries with logical
sort orders.
This'll be a very popular use
case for the composite index.
So let's move on to the
workaround part.
How can we make Datastore Query
operate at almost as
flexibly as a relational
database query?
We cannot say Datastore will be
super flexible just like an
RDB because a single Datastore
Query will
have to be super scalable.
We'll have to have certain
restrictions.
For the App Engine developer,
it's very important to
understand those restrictions
and workarounds before you
start designing your
data model.
Like the restrictions,
inequality filters and sorting
needs an index.
Inequality filters like less
than or greater than are only
applicable to the single index,
single properties.
You cannot have the query
where you are applying
inequality filters on
to two properties.
So this is one of the major
restrictions we have.
There's a very close
relationship with sorting and
the inequality filters, because
every filtering or
sorting is implemented
as an index scan.
So it means if you want to do
any sorting, you have to
prepare everything sorted
beforehand as an index table.
One of the famous restrictions
for any NoSQL database is that
JOIN is not supported.
Whenever a mission-critical
system gets so big,
denormalization issues occur.
If you're splitting this
database into multiple
instances, you cannot execute
joint operations anymore.
So if your querying like this
where you'd want to join two
different tables, like a person
and address, you may
want to put the country property
into a person, not
normalize the table,
denormalizing the table.
This means there's a trade-off
between the performance, or
scalability, and the redundancy,
or cost, of
managing multiple duplicated
values onto the
kind or many kinds.
There are some tweaks you can
emulate the joint operation in
Datastore, like this, if you
have to handle end-to-end
relationships.
In this example, each entity,
called Person, has friends.
And they have an end-to-end
relationship between person.
In a traditional relational
database, you'd have a JOIN
table called Friends table,
which represents every
relationship between
the single person.
In Datastore, you don't
have to have another
JOIN table to do that.
You can just have
a multi-valued
property like this.
Friends property may have a list
of strings, list of the
people names so that they can
write the query like this.
If you want to find a mutual
friend, who is a friend for
Bob and also a friend for
Willie, then you can write a
query like this.
Select from person where friends
equal Bob and friend
equals to Willie.
And location equals to San
Francisco, for example.
This query can be executed by
using a single-property index.
You don't have to prepare a
composite index for this query
because the Datastore will be
emerging and joining the
result from the two different
queries into one.
This means that you can
implement the end-to-end
relationship within the
Datastore result without any
JOIN operation.
You can still do this
for joining
between the same entities.
In this case, person.
This example is joining two
different result sets for the
same entities, but it's still
a major restriction that you
cannot join the different
tables.
There's another restriction, we
have a workaround for the
App Engine DataStore.
In Datastore, you cannot
execute any GROUP BY
operations, or aggregate
functions.
More specifically, you cannot
execute counts from table.
So you cannot count the
number of entities
you have right now.
To be scalable, you don't have
time to look at all the
entities and count them all.
You do have a workaround having
a special entity that
maintains aggregates by you,
like a counter entity, which
holds the number of entities
you've created.
If you're doing this, however,
you have to be careful about
the entity's bottleneck.
There are limitations, like the
one entity can only get
one update per second.
This is not a physical limit,
but it's kind of a design
property you have to follow.
Because of this restriction,
you cannot simply have one
counter entity to count many
accesses from the users.
There's a design element called
a sharding counter
where you are sharding the
counters into multiple
entities and gather aggregated
results later.
You can alternatively use
memcache as a holder for that
count value.
Then, use Datastore as
well to back up the
latest count number.
It's hard to implement a counter
or any aggregate
function on the Datastore.
If it's not required to get
the aggregated value
instantly, then you can do
it later by using batch
processing by using a
back end instance.
There's also a very useful open
source framework called
App Engine MapReduce, which is
using task queue to emulate
the MapReduce framework.
We won't discuss details about
the App Engine MapReduce, but
this can efficiently handle
batch operations on huge
amounts of entities
on Datastore.
Finally, if it's not urgent,
then you can just rely on the
Statistics API of
the Datastore.
Datastore provides statistics
data, like how many entries
you have or what kind by
accessing the API for that,
and those numbers will be
updated once per day.
So it's a very large number,
but still, you can use that
for certain usages.
Moving onto the aggregation
function restrictions.
You cannot use the minimum
function or maximum function
like you have in your
relational database.
You may want to have a single
property and sort it ascending
or descending so that you can
find the first entity on the
index to get the minimum
value or maximum value.
This technique in Datastore
allows you to have an
aggregated value, like a count
or average, or a maximum,
while the order of login speed
by using a data structure
called Skiplist.
Skiplist is very similar
to a binary or B tree.
Just like a tree search, you
don't have to look for every
single node to find a node.
You can start finding it
from the express lane.
The trick is, you can just add
the aggregate values on each
express lane to get
the aggregated
value on the Datastore.
Using this data structure, you
can obtain the average or a
maximal or minimum values of a
range of entries in a very
short time period.
You don't have to scan all the
entities in the range.
For example, how many entities
do you have from the
node 1 to node 6?
Using the level 3 express lane,
you find 3, and then you
add 2 so that the answer
will be 5.
There are 5 nodes between
node 1 and node 6.
An important thing to
consider is the cost
of indexing in Datastore.
This is a real application which
has an entity with only
25 megabytes.
However, it consumes a total
of 238 megabytes somehow.
The rest of the space is taken
up by the indexes because that
entity has so many
single-property index tables
for each property.
It means you need to have 10
times larger index space than
the entity itself.
This is another big difference
between the Datastore and a
traditional database.
If you want to cost estimate
Datastore accurately, then you
have to think about the cost
of index in terms of space.
You may also want to check
your document called
understanding right cost, which
explains the CPU cost
you consume for building
the index.
For every single entity write or
update, it will also update
the single-property index or
custom index you have created.
When you are using hundreds of
index tables, that means
updates can take a
very long time.
And now to discuss some
final caveats.
There are no aggregation
functions like the lower or
upper, or any other functions.
You may want to pre-process or
pre-calculate the value,
putting an additional property
on the entities so that you
can implement it.
Because Datastore doesn't
support Search, there's a very
useful new API called
Search API, which
supports full text search.
It converts every query into the
index scan or key, so it
means you cannot be applying the
irregular expressions Full
Text Search on the index scan.
So instead of using Datastore,
we may recommend you look into
the Search API for
full text search.
When you're using the query,
you may not see that result
instantly, returning the
old data instead.
To avoid this, you should
use Ancestor Query.
Ancestor Query guarantees
strong consistency.
It means you're always
getting the latest
result of your updates.
And lastly, there's a
combinational explosion
phenomenon that can happen on
large value properties.
If you're having multiple
large-valued properties on the
query or index, because
multiple large-valued
properties on the index, there
will be a 10 times 10 log of
combinations of the index.
So you need to be careful when
you're using the multiple
large-valued properties on
your query or index.
Let's now describe how
transactions can work in Datastore.
Now you understand how Datastore
can be scalable with
its unique practice
like data scan.
It's time now to understand the
transactional aspects in Datastore.
In Datastore, you design your
data model based on
consistency requirements.
This is one point which is not
required in traditional RDBs.
In traditional relational
database models, you don't
have to care about the
transactional requirement when
you're designing your schema.
But in Datastore, the data model
is closely related to
the transactional requirement.
So by designing carefully, your
data model can make your
application super scalable
and yet, consistent.
So what is a transaction?
This is a recap of the general
concepts of transactions.
If you have any experience on
the traditional database, then
you already know the concept of
the ACID characteristics,
but I'd like to recap.
In short, it stands for the
Atomicity, Consistency, and
Isolation and Durability
required for every
transaction.
A transaction is a series
of operations on
your record or entity.
If you have a user entity and
want to execute a series of
operation, like updating the
name of a user or the age
property of a user, those series
of operations can be a
transaction.
Originally, transactions were
invented for a mainframe
environment, so were robust
and consistent.
Whenever you have a hardware
failure or application bugs,
or getting so many requests from
the users, no matter how
things can happen, they want to
make everything consistent
or reliable for business
purposes.
To do that, the transaction
should support the atomicity,
like whenever you have a
hardware failure or a software
failure or a transaction
during the transaction
execution, the result should
be all or nothing.
There should be no partially
applied or
inconsistent result.
Ensure that any transaction will
bring the datastore from
one valid state or another.
As I mentioned, every
transaction should be applied
in a way that there is no
partially applied state.
Isolation means more like it's
talking about the situation
where you're getting so many
requests from so many users at
the same time, like updating one
bank account from multiple
ATMs, can break isolation
or consistency.
So your Datastore database has
to prevent that by isolating
each transaction.
Durability means you have to use
a hard disk drive to store
the result of the Datastore
updates.
If you're storing everything in
memory, you will not have
any durability.
So transaction means your
application is robust and
consistent.
For simpler applications,
which don't require
robustness, then you don't
have to take care of
transactions.
A hobby application, for
example, you don't have to use
the transaction Entity Group
I'll be discussing.
Entity Group is the most
important concept when
learning Datastore
transactions.
Because of the name, you may
think that it's related to the
one to n relationship
between tables in
their traditional database.
Actually, it's not.
It's just a scope
of transaction.
It doesn't need any entity
relationship we have in the
traditional database.
It's a scope of transactions.
Each entity has its own Entity
Group by default.
It's just like if you are
person, then you are a family.
We all are.
Your family originally
consists of
just one, just yourself.
But you can grow your family.
Each entity has a single
Entity Group.
So there are five different
Entity Groups here.
Having a parent and child
relationship between them, it
can create one Entity Group.
So this grandpa has so many
children, a successor like dad
and grandpa.
This can work out as a scope
of a transaction.
And transaction's integrity or
consistency can be secured
with this group, not among the
different Entity Groups.
A potentially confusing part
is the key of an entity is
very important part to clear
this Entity Group
relationship.
If you're adding more and more
children or successors to an
entity, the successor would
have an ancestor path.
This is a totally new thing
that was not used in
traditional database.
Every single key has an ID to
identify each entity, but also
has their ancestor, which
describes who is the ancestor--
dad, or grandpa, or yourself.
Two formal Entity Group
relationships.
This is somewhat difficult
to understand.
This is all for transactions.
This is not a relationship
between the tables in a
traditional database.
To create this kind of Entity
Group relationship, you may
want to create this kind of code
when you're creating a
new entity.
You may want to specify the
kind of name and ID of
yourself and of the entity, and
the parent's key, so that
it would create the total
whole key like this--
the key with the
ancestor path.
To use the transaction, you
can write like this.
This is very similar code to
the traditional way of
handling a transaction
with an RDB.
To tell the Datastore to begin
and after writing everything,
then you would want to commit
that transaction.
If an unexpected error or
exception occurs, then you
would want to roll
back everything.
This means canceling all the
updates done during the
transaction, so that you'll
get the atomicity of the
transaction.
This is the same as the ordinary
way of controlling
transactions, but the difference
is that the
transaction will be rolled back
based on the Entity Group
relationship.
If you're updating 1,000 rows
during a transaction, then the
rollback will be canceling
all the updates
for the 1,000 rows.
But in the case of a Datastore,
the rollback will
be applied only to
the Entity Group.
That's the difference.
I'd like to mention an
important new feature
introduced recently called
Cross-Group Transaction.
You can have up to five Entity
Groups in a transaction.
However, remember that all
queries will use eventual, not
strong consistency.
If you design an Entity Group,
you should make sure that
every single Entity Group will
not receive over one update
transaction per second.
In practice, it can handle
closer to five per second, but
this could be a bottleneck
for your application.
Because the datastore needs to
control the transaction across
each Entity Group, this means
sometimes we have to maintain
consistency between
data centers.
It can be a global
transaction.
These are some of the
key takeaways--
how a Datastore works in a
Query, restrictions of Queries
and Workarounds, and how the
Entity Group is a scope of
transactions in Datastore.
Finally, here are some useful
resources to learn more about
advanced Datastore concepts
discussed during this lesson.